der panorama zu
man kann sich zurücklehnen und
entspannen auf einen luxus trip durch
kanada
wir haben die beste crew der welt
durch unberührte wildnis
wunderschön vor bayern beeindruckende
bauwerk ich bin im engineering
der fahrt ins herz der marke mountain
wir sind in den spielertunnel
ich finde heraus was hinter den kulissen
passiert wenn dieser fünf sterne zug
über die gleise rolle
die kanadischen rocky mountains locken
jedes jahr mehr als neun millionen
touristen an
viele von ihnen lassen die wanderschuhe
zu hause und erkunden die berge auf
schienen an bord einer ganz besonderen
eisenbahn
toller tag seit 1990 bietet die firma
rocky mountaineer zugfahrten durch
westkanada
zwei der beliebtesten routen führen
mitten durch die rocky mountains
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gute nummer eins beginnt in british
columbia
von vancouver geht es entlang des fraser
river nach kamloops und weiter durchs
gebirge nach bern in der provinz alberta
die
zweite fahrt startet in jasper im herzen
der rockies und schlängelt sich von dort
entlang des hudson river über kamloops
zurück nach vancouver
[Musik]
früh morgens am container terminal in
vancouver
zugchef in niemegk michael und die 76
crewmitglieder sind seit dem
morgengrauen war bis zur abfahrt um 8
muss alles fertig sein
[Musik]
2500 dollar kostet ein platz in der
exklusiven gold leaf klassen da zählt
jedes detail ein normaler morgen
vor der abfahrt haben alle eine menge zu
tun
wie groß ist diese zu
haben heute 540 fahrgäste an bord und
der zug besteht aus 20 teilen also ganz
schön lang
für die technik ist jason clarke
verantwortlich
ich bin der bordmechaniker oder wie wir
sagen die auf see
bevor es losgeht überprüft er die
drehgestelle der zwei loks und 18
waggons
sie managen die ganze logistik und
technik
logistik technik alles mechanisch das
sind die aufgaben des teams sehen dazu
ist gewaltig oder er ein ganz großer zu
zwei generator wagen versorgen das
rollende monstrum mit strom
fahren das ding jetzt hoch damit der
ganze zug genügend saft hat
ein mechaniker stellt sicher dass die
maschinen einwandfrei laufen
das ist ein keller diesel-generator
biturbo zwölfzylinder bringt rund 650 ps
jeder generator ist mit zwei tanks
verbunden die zusammen 7000 400 liter
diesel fassen
das reicht locker für 48 stunden
der kraftstoff treibt einen motor an den
generator in drehung versetzt und so
strom erzeugt extra große ventilatoren
sorgen dafür dass die maschine dabei
nicht überhitzen wir machen eine
gründliche inspektion damit die
kommenden tage alles glatt
sobald der strom fließt startet wenn die
mit merkel ihren morgendlichen kontroll
rundgang
ich prüfe jetzt ob die verbindungstüren
geschlossen sind
wenn wir losfahren muss alles gesichert
sein
die erfahrenen lokführer golden bear und
ran.de rinnstein den zug auf dem ersten
streckenabschnitt mal kern lux
ich stelle heute die weichen
ihr platz ist in der vorderen lokomotive
sie ist 18 meter lang knapp fünf meter
hoch und etwa drei meter breit mit ihrem
3000 ps starken 16 zylinder motor
schafft sie bis zu 105 kilometer pro
stunde
mittlerweile sind auch die fahrgäste
eingetroffen
[Applaus]
passagiere in russland darf das signal
zum ansteigen geben
wie immer ertönt leicht die zukäufe und
dann bitten wir alle herein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herrlicher tag für den rocky mountains
kann ich mit drauf gerne danke
[Musik]
jason schock gibt ihn noch für grünes
licht auf geht's wir können planmäßig ab
fahren wenn gleich sechs frei ist machen
wir uns auf den weg
[Musik]
wir lassen den bahnhof hinter uns und
fahren jetzt richtung rockies ich bin
gespannt
[Musik]
die fast 1000 kilometer lange etappe
beginnt in lernkurve folgt dem lauf des
fraser river und macht dann einen
schlenker richtung kamloops da eine
übernachtung geht es weiter nach rostock
vorbei am lake louis zur endstation in
alberta
unser team wird sich gut um sie kümmern
und sie auf die highlights aufmerksam
machen
der zug hat vier einstöckige silva lief
und sieben doppelstöckige gold leaf
waggons mit glaskuppel der panoramablick
kommt bestimmt gut an
er gibt der zugfahrt einen romantischen
touch
wer hunger hat geht runter in den
speisewagen und lässt sich dort ein
gourmet essen schmecken bei perfekter
aussicht versteht sich
während draußen die landschaft vorbei
zieht geht es hier drinnen richtig zur
sache was für ein gemüse
jeder gold leaf waggon hat eine eigene
küche kaum größer als ein
frachtcontainer wir bereiten alles ganz
frisch zu
alles frisch der preisgekrönte
küchenchef pia der
feinschmecker menüs aus regionalen
zutaten
so machen wir das
nicht eine komplette küche auf engstem
raum wie funktioniert das können sie mir
das erklären
alles was sie hier sehen ist
maßgefertigt
abgestimmt auf die bedürfnisse des rocky
mountain die abzugs haben die
kühlschränke und fast alle geräte sind
mehrfach vorhanden wenn 1 ausfällt gibt
es ersatz wie in einem flugzeug und
diese stoffe verhindern dass etwas
ausrutscht
die eröffnung hier ist schmaler als die
teller wenn es mal ruck hat bleibt
trotzdem alles an seinem platz
eine küche auf engstem raum sie sich
bewegt wie eine achterbahn
und in der sich niemand verletzen
[Musik]
nach einem leckeren frühstück genießen
die fahrgäste den blick über den fraser
river
[Musik]
die landschaft ist atemberaubend schön
schön aber schwer zugänglich gordon love
griff weiß welche herausforderungen die
ingenieure meistern mussten um hier
gleise zu verlegen
was ist das besondere an diesem zug und
an dieser strecke
für mich ganz klar die ingenieurskunst
dahinter wie die bedingungen hier sind
wahnsinnig schwierig allein schon das
planen und vermessen war eine enorme
leistung
anfang der 1880 begann die firma
canadian pacific railway mit dem bau der
transkontinentalen
eisenbahnstrecke doch die berge im
westen hätten das vorhaben fast
vorzeitig beendet
in der prärie haben sie pro tag acht
kilometer geschafft aber dann kam der
125 kilometer lange abschnitt durch die
rocky mountains dafür haben sie fast ein
ganzes jahr gebraucht außer handwerks
zeugen hatten sie nur einen dampfbad und
der kam nicht überall hin kurz dahinter
wartete die nächste hürde der fraser
canyon mit der berühmten fluss enge
herrscht geld der entdecker sein und
fraser meinte der ort sei zu gefährlich
für menschen darum nannte er ihn tor zur
hölle
die enge ist ungefähr 200 kilometer von
vancouver entfernt der rocky mountain er
fährt genau darauf zu
wir sind jetzt tief im fraser canyon und
da vorne wo die schlucht ganz schmal
wird ist das hells gate
jede minute strömen dort hunderte
millionen liter wasser durch
etwa doppelt so viel wie bei den niagara
fällen
die stelle ist wunderschön aber auch
extrem gefährlich der name hell's gate
trifft das ganz gut
die bahnstrecke am fraser canyon zu
bauen war ein hartes stück arbeit
die einzige versorgungsroute nach
vancouver war eine schmale straße wenn
die blockiert war durch einen erdrutsch
oder schlechtes wetter konnte man nicht
weiterfahren
der us ingenieur andrew handel dank war
dafür bekannt selbst schwierigste
projekte zu meistern er nahm den auftrag
an und brachte eine ganze arbeiter schar
aus den usa und aus china mit
5000 kamen aus den usa und 10.000
auskannten in china die chinesen wurden
schlechter bezahlt als die
amerikanischen arbeiter und mussten
gefährliche aufgaben wie fels
sprengungen übernehmen
erst mit serien der fünfjährigen bauzeit
sind in british columbia zwischen 600
und 1000 arbeiter umgekommen
ohne ihren einsatz könnte der rocky
mountain er diese reise heute nicht
unternehmen
zweieinhalb stunden südwestlich von kern
loops genießen die gäste die aussicht
aus den panoramafenstern
hier drin hat man man kann mit anderen
fahrgästen plaudern und gleichzeitig den
rundumblick genießen und fotos machen
[Musik]
uns sind die panoramafenster der gut
lief oberdecks im stadler werk in berlin
entsteht unterdessen eine neue
generation von luxus waggons
50 ingenieure haben daran mitgearbeitet
deutsch schweizerischen hightech wagen
stecken voller extras darunter dem
banner fensterscheiben
die passagiere können die tönung der
scheiben beliebig einstellen je nach
wetterlage
das geheimnis sind millionen licht
absorbierende partikel die sich per
drehschalter elektrisch steuern lassen
erhöht man die spannung entstehen lücken
zwischen den partikeln und das
lichtkanten durchscheinen senkt man die
spannung rücken die partikel zusammen
gut aus für dunkel
[Musik]
wenn es sonnig ist kann man die scheiben
verdunkeln und wenn es bewölkt ist
wieder heller machen
alles innerhalb von ein wunder der
technik
der rocky mountain er überquert
unterdessen den fraser river und steuert
auf die trockeneren prärie regionen zu
schau dir den
fisch
draußen wird es jetzt richtig war die
klimaanlage springt an doch sie bläst zu
heftig jason hart geht in den generator
wagen um die einstellungen anzupassen
über diesen schalter kann ich die
gewünschte raumtemperatur einstellen
wenn ich sie ein wenig höher drehen geht
die klimaanlage in den ruhemodus und
wird auch so stark zu kühlen dann müssen
unsere gäste nicht mehr frieren
eine stunde später erreicht der zug die
ortschaft ashcroft knapp 100 kilometer
westlich von konsums
diese verkohlte bäume da drüben sind das
überreste der letzten waldbrände
das feuer hat nördlich von ashcroft
angefangen und sich hangabwärts bis zum
flussufer ausgebreitet es war furchtbar
die ganze gegend musste evakuiert werden
im sommer 2017 wüteten in british
columbia
die schlimmsten waldbrände seit beginn
der aufzeichnungen
er hat ein großes feuer in der nähe von
mount im krieg auch die bahnstrecke
eingefahren
das feuer erstreckte sich über 1000
hektar und der wind hat die flammen in
richtung der schienen geblasen
wir mussten löschflugzeuge und
hubschrauber
durch ihren einsatz konnten die
mannschaften das schlimmste abwenden
unsere große schneisen geschlagen
brandherde gelöscht zu haben jetzt nach
tagen geschafft das feuer von der
bahnlinie fernzuhalten
alles frei
frei
an bord des rocky mountaineer macht die
klimaanlage immer noch probleme jason
schlag ist mit seinem latein am ende
wir wollen dass sich die leute im zug
wohl fühlen und das ist mit einer
defekten klimaanlage schwierig darum
lassen wir sie heute abend in kamloops
durchchecken
[Musik]
bis dahin ist es zum glück nicht mehr
weit
[Musik]
sie können zum bahnsteig kommen danke
während die fahrgäste kamloops sekunden
geht es für den rocky mountaineer über
nacht in die wartungshalle
[Musik]
die wartungs crew macht sich sofort an
die arbeit es gibt viel zu tun wir haben
nur sieben stunden zeit
[Musik]
das sind die kabel die den zug mit strom
versorgen
elektriker matters untersucht wie
defekte klimaanlage die eingaben haben
nicht das gewünschte ergebnis gebracht
warum tauschen die jetzt die orange box
das ist sozusagen das gehirn der anlage
jeder passagier war grohl ist mit einem
computer ausgestattet der heizung und
klimaanlage steuert
er sitzt in einem orangefarbenen gehäuse
dann schalten wir sie mal ein
die ventilatoren laufen alles
funktioniert die gäste werden sich
morgen wohl fühlen elektriker wayne
bridge testet er weil ein anderes
wichtiges gerät
das ist unsere black box
in kanada müssen alle lokomotiven mit
einem rekorder ausgestattet sein der
daten die die geschwindigkeit gefahrener
kilometer und bremst einsatz aufzeigt
in diesem modul stecken eine kamera und
ein mikrofon die alles aufnehmen was im
führerstand passiert dann gibt es noch
eine zweite kamera die auf die strecke
gerichtet ist alles was die lokführer
tun wird also aufgezeichnet
weiter hinten entdeckt mechaniker kevin
djokovic ein paar abgenutzte bremsbeläge
waggon gibt es acht brands setzte also
eine ganze menge aber
[Musik]
ist ein kinderspiel
für einen zug der durch raue ist erfährt
ist gründlicher wartung das a und o
manche gefahren lassen sich denn auch
nicht vermeiden
[Musik]
nach der übernachtung in kamloops gehen
die fahrgäste wieder an bord
toller erster tag im rocky mountaineer
der trip durch die rocky mountains geht
weiter rx 80 12 ost ich höre
angekauft hat bereits abfahrt
mit dem zug die steilen anstiege schafft
wird eine dritte lockt angekoppelt
[Musik]
die 500 kilometer lange route führt an
revel stock vorbei über den rogers ps
und in columbia und kicking horse river
bis zum lake louis und ende den bands
gleich ist der vorbei
dann haben wir frei bahn
ganz vorne sitzen die lokführer terrible
und mike liegen vor ihrem jetzigen job
haben die beiden 35 jahre lang güterzüge
gefahren ich habe 1977 in revel stock
angefangen und 2012 in kamloops
aufgehört seit 2013 fahre ich den rocky
mountains
liegen freut sich dass er jetzt also wir
befördern darf der job hat bei ihm
familientradition
ich komme aus einer eisen seiner familie
mein vater war heitzer für meinen
großvater mein großvater war fast 50
jahre dabei mein vater 42 jahre dann
habe ich noch drei brüder die auch alle
lokführer waren das muss wahre liebe
sein
[Musik]
auf einer luxus bahnreisen liegt die
latte besonders hoch alles muss glatt
gehen
unsere gäste sind das wichtigste wir tun
unser bestes um ihnen die reise so
angenehm wie möglich zu machen
darum dürfen nur erfahrene lokführer den
rocky mountaineer steuer
verglichen mit schweren güterzügen fährt
sich der rookie wie ein sportwagen
selbst bei angst liegend verliert der
kaum an geschwindigkeit auf einer kürze
ist da kommen andere züge nicht mit
nach eineinhalb stunden fahrt erreicht
er zog den schwaben
gleich kommt ihr haus ja noch ein paar
minuten
das land lebt in cairns
einen modernen holzfäller dorf entlang
der route
mein vater war auch bei der bahn
ich bin praktisch zwischen bahnhöfen
groß geworden sie ist ein großer fan des
rock im unternehmen
immer wenn ich ihn kommen sie sage ich
doris bescheid dann läuft sie raus und
lenkt sie kann einfach nicht anders
zum dank für ihre treuen dürfen sie und
ihr mann brian heute als ehrengäste mit
fragen
warum winken sie nah war so nahe ist und
weil er so viel liebe und wärme
verströmt
frau viele leute
fans freunde und familie haben sich vor
ihrem haus versammelt um ihr zuzuwinken
eine überraschung organisiert von der
mountain eher cool unglaublich
[Applaus]
entstanden entlang der trasse rund 800
neue gemeinden
wir sind jetzt ein schickes und fahren
richtung levels tag hinter der brücke
bremsen wir von 50 auf 25 an also
festhalten
nach einer flotten fahrt über das
hochland drosselt die in das tempo
gleich kommt der letzte nagel ein gutes
foto motiv
[Musik]
dort wo die steinpyramide steht wurde im
november
1885 der letzte schienen nagel
eingeschlagen das war ein wichtiger
moment nicht nur für die bahnstrecke
es hat geholfen kanada als nation zu
vereinen
nach jahren harter arbeit weil die trans
kanadische eisenbahnstrecke endlich
fertig zum ersten mal konnte man in
kanada von einer küste zur anderen
reisen
diese strecke hat geholfen den westen zu
erschließen und güter von hier in den
osten zu bringen
beide seiten haben also davon
profitieren
außerdem wurde in kanada eine
einheitliche zeit festgelegt die
eisenbahn zeit
vor der eisenbahn zeit stellten die
kanadier ihre uhren einfach nach der
sonne in jedem dorf und in jeder stadt
liefen sie also an wenige anders
statt fünf zehn oder 15 minuten
voneinander abzuweichen hatten alle
dörfer jetzt dieselbe uhrzeit natürlich
nur bis die offiziellen zeitzonen
eingeführt wurde
am frühen nachmittag erreicht der zug
den gleichen nationalpark in den selkirk
mountains gut 200 km westlich von bern
zeit für einen kleinen rundflug
noch beeindruckender
wenn es auf diesem steilen
streckenabschnitt ein problem gibt
kommen hubschrauberpiloten wie mark
adams zur hilfe
[Musik]
was sind da dieser gegen die größten
gefahren für einen zug
vor allem die naturgewalten erdrutsche
können das gleiche mensch lamm oder
schnee die strecke blockieren liefert
adams aus der vogelperspektive wichtige
informationen er sieht wo das gleis frei
geräumt werden muss und ob weitere
erdrutsche drohen
vielen jahren eine bahnstrecke gebaut
hat das scheint fast unmöglich
es damals nicht mal straßen stimmt in
westkanada gibt es mehr brücken und
tunnel pro gleiskilometer als irgendwo
sonst in nordamerika
beeindruckende konstruktion gebaut mit
einfachsten bernd sein
der pferde kamen die ausrüstung
herangeschafft
dann auf dem holz der umgebung die bahn
schon gefertigt
und schließt nicht die stahlschienen
verlegt
mit gewinnen aus
ist die lawinengefahr sehr groß die
bahnstrecke die schnellstraße alles in
dieser gegend es gefährdet
[Musik]
weiter geht's in richtung kicking horse
pass wo das nächste meisterwerk der
ingenieurskunst wartet
fahren wir in die weltberühmten
spielertunnel zwei große care tunnel
tief in den bergen sie wurden gebaut um
die steigung an dieser stelle so niedrig
wie möglich zu halten
die gleise führen über den kicking horse
river in den tunnel des mount orten
drehen sie eine fast 1000 meter lange
schleife und komme dann 15 meter höhe
wieder an die oberfläche
kathrin merten wiederholt sich das ganze
nur in die andere richtung
dadurch haben wir doppelt so viel
strecke aber nur halb soviel steigung
2,2 statt 4,5
gemächlich rollt der zug an den
steilwänden der rocky mountains vorbei
absolut in dieser gegend leben viele
wilde tiere die fahrgäste halten
gespannt ausschau
[Musik]
was hier hinter mir ist ein viel
genutzter wildtier
über diesen weg gelangen bären und
andere tiere zum gleis
doch so eindrucksvolles ist einen bären
aus der nähe zu sehen
in den gleisen möchte man ihn lieber
nicht haben
[Musik]
auf seinem weg durch die rockies kommt
der rocky mountain er plötzlich zu
stehen
rx 80 12 hat ein stoppsignal erhalten
wir müssen auf zwei züge warten
zwei lange güterzüge kommen aus der
gegenrichtung der rocky mountaineer muss
sie vorbei lassen
[Musik]
wir sollten ein zusätzliches essen
anbieten
die küchencrew liegt den turbogang 1
wir planen ein bisschen um unser wären
jetzt allen fahrgästen ein leichtes
abendessen
im handumdrehen bereiten die köche von
140 zusätzliche mahlzeit mischungen
200 kilometer südlich in der zug
leitstelle von calgary wird die
vorbeifahrt der züge überwacht
[Musik]
bei 565 redgrave michael crow managed
alle züge zwischen ravensburg und vier
in british columbia
71 zwischen signal 991
75 weiterfahren heute muss crew dem
zeitplan des rocky mountaineer
durcheinanderbringen mit so vielen
leuten an bord hat der rocky mountaineer
natürlich erst mal vorrang aber wenn der
verkehr so ist wie heute können wir
nichts machen dann müssen sie auch mal
warten oder eine weile hinter einem
güterzug erfahren
eineinhalb stunden später dann die
ersehnte nachricht
wir haben freigabe
die passagiere nehmen die verspätung
gelassen und genießen die aussicht auf
den
zu dieser tageszeit sind oft bären und
andere wilde tiere unterwegs
manche kommen ganz nah an die gleise
heran mitunter sogar ein wenig zu nahe
[Musik]
leider laufen in dieser gegend öffnet er
über die schienen besonders
wenn ein güterzug getreide verliert
kommen sie um zu fressen schaffen es
dann manchmal nicht mehr rechtzeitig weg
louis fressen gerne schachtelhalme und
büffel und die wachsen entlang der route
besonders leicht
mittlerweile sind die frakturen zu einem
echten problem geworden
in den letzten 17 jahren gab es 17
unfälle wenn das so weitergeht ist der
bestand ernsthaft gesetzt collien casa
de saint clair und ihr team erforschen
wie es zu den unfällen kommt und wie man
sie verhindern kann
die tiere bemerken den zukauf erst zu
spät vielleicht weil er aus einer kurve
kommt weil es dunkel ist oder regnet
um das verhalten der bären noch besser
zu verstehen haben die biologen die
strecke mit kamerafallen bestückt
jedes mal wenn ein zug vorbei kommt
schießt die kamera fotos 2 pro sekunde
45 sekunden lang egal ob ein tier da ist
oder nicht so haben wir in neun monaten
zweieinhalb millionen fotos gesammelt
daran sehen wir wie lange die tiere auf
den schulen
das verblüffende ergebnis
grizzlys brauchen im schnitt 30 sekunden
um sich vor einem herannahenden zug in
sicherheit zu bringen
uns wurde klar dass wir ein warnsystem
brauchen
um den tieren mehr zeit zu verschaffen
hat das team ein frühwarnsystem
entwickelt
es besteht aus zwei geräten die am gleis
angebracht werden der lautsprecher ist
unten fährt ein zug über die erste box
registriert wie die erschütterung und
sendet ein funksignal an die zweite box
700 meter entfernt diese gibt daraufhin
eine reihe von licht und tonsignalen ab
die die tiere vom gleichen sinn
wenn der alarm losgeht verlassen die
tiere das gleis im schnitt fünf sekunden
schneller diese fünf sekunden könnten
über leben und tod entscheiden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die stimmung im zug ist super eine
verspätung muss nicht immer schlecht
sein die landschaft
bei mondschein ist das alles mindestens
so schön wir bei tageslicht
[Musik]
darum ist auch niemand verärgert als der
zug mit eineinhalbstündiger verspätung
in band 1 fährt
jason wenn die bremsen sind angezogen
danke thesen mandy anzug bremsen sind
angezogen bereits zum aussteigen
willkommen
vielen dank
bislang hatten wir eine tolle reise über
flüsse schluchten und durch die rocky
mountains und morgen fahren wir sogar
durch die wolken
auch den höchsten streckenabschnitten
schützt modernste hightech den rocky
mountaineer vor unfällen
ein defektes lager kann den zug
entgleisen lassen das müssen wir
verhindern
die fahrt von vancouver nach bern ist zu
ende
einfach herrlich aber das abenteuer geht
weiter tripp nummer 2 beginnt in der
gemeinde jasper
da sind wir
ein schöner morgen aber etwas kühl oder
der bahnhof wurde 1911 gebaut zeitgleich
mit der grand trank pacific railway
strecke sie sollte den handel in der
region ankurbeln
nach der spektakulären ersten fahrt kann
ich die zweite kaum erwarten wir starten
von den rockies aus richtung westküste
[Musik]
die tausend kilometer lange route führt
über den yellow herpes vorbei am mount
robson und den perron mit vier cent
landes tamsen river nach kamloops
anschließend folgt sie dem frazer river
zurückgaben
lasst uns anstoßen auf neue freunde neue
alte und eine wundervolle reise
nach 90 minuten das erste highlight
dieser riesige schneebedeckten berg da
drüben ist der mount robson er ist mit
fast 4000 metern der höchste berg der
kanadischen rockies dass wir so gut
sehen können ist übrigens nicht
selbstverständlich ist fast das ganze
jahr über in wolken gehüllt wir haben
also riesiges glück
ohne die bahnlinie durch die rocky
mountains würden solche anblicke den
meisten fahrgästen verwehrt bleiben
nach gut 100 kilometer durch die berge
erreicht der zug die siedlung take your
cash von dort geht es weiter nach
kamloops
stell den kleinen auf 8 ich gehe auf 1
und st
offenbar gibt es probleme mit dem gleis
das wartungsteam ist schon unterwegs
jan und robin ein stück der bahnstrecke
ist kaputt und muss repariert werden es
wäre schön wenn jemand kurz den gästen
bescheid sagen könnte
ihnen werden zwar selten beschädigt aber
wenn dann ist das immer sehr lästig je
nachdem wann die arbeiter kommen und wie
lange sie schweißen müssen kann das
schon mal länger dauern
[Musik]
weiter östlich bringt techniker chet
baker einen anderen streckenabschnitt
mit hightech auf vordermann
das ist ein so genannter will impact
laut detector er wiegt hinzu und
übertrifft den zustand jedes einzelnen
rades
die belastungs sensoren messen die
verformung des balls so sehen wir wie
schwer dazu gischt mängel hat
ist der zug überladen oder sind die
räder beschädigt könnten die schienen
unter der belastung brechen
wir wegen diesen zug und suche nach
gefahrenquellen
diese dumpfen schläge das sind flach
stellen an den rädern
mit unseren sensoren können wir messen
wie groß diese flach stellen sind
in nahegelegenen messstationen werden
die daten analysiert
jeder waggon hat einen kleinen funkchip
wenn der wagen vorbei fährt wird der
chip gescannt und wir wissen genau
welches rad zu erwarten muss
609 fährt weiter richtung westen frei
des stopp signal
für den rocky mountain er geht es
endlich weiter
los geht's
der zug der sich dem kern nur über
wir sind jetzt auf der kennedybrücke
hier gab es 1950 ein schlimmes zugrunde
der rocky mountain er wahrt sich weiter
seinen weg durch bewaldete taylor sie
sehen zwar idyllisch aus werben aber
gefahren jeder von uns hat hier schon
mal eine brenzlige situation erlebt
regelmäßig kreuzen schweren laster die
schienen
kommst mit 80 um die kurve und plötzlich
kriegt vor dir einen truck über das
gleis das kann richtig eng werden
dank moderner signalsysteme sind unfälle
heute selten doch das war nicht immer so
am 21 november 1950 fuhr ein zug mit 338
soldaten an bord auf der trans
continental strecke richtung westen als
plötzlich ein zug aus der gegenrichtung
kann die beiden stießen frontal zusammen
17 soldaten und vier lokführer kamen ums
leben
auf der anderen seite steht ein denkmal
für die opfer
heutzutage gibt es einheitliche signale
und computer die verhindern dass
zugleiter entgegenkommende züge auf
dasselbe gleis lassen außerdem checken
die lokführer jedes signal doppel
freilich hätte frei bis mitte
[Musik]
auf dem weg nach süden wartet ein
weiteres naturspektakel
das sind die pyramid falls riesige von
gletschern gespeiste wasserfälle die
sind über 90 meter hoch und in voller
pracht kann man sie nur vom zug aus
sehen
noch dreieinhalb stunden bis vancouver
und der zug schlängelt sich durch den
steinigen thompson river canyon
gleich sehen sie draußen den rainbow
canyon und die ärmel
auf den nächsten kilometern passieren
wir 33 schutz galerien sie fangen
herabfallende steine ab und lenken sie
in den fluss
seit mehr als 130 jahren schützen die
sogenannten galerien züge von
steinschlag und der abschnitt wird noch
mehr risiken auch das gleisbett macht
hin und wieder probleme
wenn es im frühling regnet gerät viel
schlamm in bewegung und die gleise
werden instabil
dasselbe passiert im sommer wenn sich
der stall durch die hitze verziehen das
einzige was dagegen hilft ist ein gutes
schotterbett
die schottersteinen stabilisieren die
schienen und helfen das gewicht der züge
gleichmäßig zu verteilen
ohne schotter geht es nicht er hält
alles zusammen
mit einem riesigen sauger hält das team
den schotter in schuss
mit der zeit nutzen sich die steine ab
dann müssen wir sie aus dem gleisbett
entfernen schaden
die maschine sagt abgeschriebenen
schotter ein einigten und lehrt den
schritt dann neben der fahrbahn aus
danach füllen die arbeiter neuer
steinchen nach ohne unsere arbeit werden
unbrauchbar
ein gutes schotterbett ist extrem
wichtig
[Musik]
auch für den rocky mountains
der panoramazug nähert sich dem großen
bahnbetriebswerk fountain jahr
hoffentlich ist das gleis frei
und von darüber nach in jurist fenster
ein glück dass kein schiff kommt wasser
fahrzeuge haben bei der drehbrücke
nämlich vorfahrt
[Musik]
das war die letzte hürde der rest ist
ein kinderspiel
nur noch eine halbe stunde bis vancouver
[Musik]
gerade und diese jahreszeit wenn die
tage kürzer sind will man möglichst noch
bei tageslicht ankommen das schaffen wir
heute locker deshalb sind alle zufrieden
auch die crew
eine exklusive panoramafahrt in den
bergen kanadas der rocky mountaineer ist
unterwegs auf einer der
beeindruckendsten
bahnstrecken der welt
alles gute hier das war super danke
was für ein tolles abenteuer der service
ist vom feinsten und die panoramawagen
bieten einen genialen ausblick
dass durch so ein gebirge überhaupt
eisenbahnen fahren ist einfach der
wahnsinn
[Musik]